Hello and welcome to the next video on the course for an introduction to procedural content
generation. In this case, we're going to be carrying on the de-exercise, and we're going
to be adding some grass and flowers to our forest. Okay, so I'm going to start off in
a very similar way. I'm going to get the landscape data, I'm going to drag out, and
I'm going to do a surface sampler. Now, we want a lot more points than what we previously
had. So I am going to come into the details panel, I'm going to change the points per
squared meter to 5. I'm going to change the extents to be considerably smaller, so I'm
going to go 10, 10, 10. I'm also going to hit the button for unbounded. Now, if
we jump back into the level, first of all, if I hit the D key so we can see where
these points are, jump back into the level, you can see that we have lots and lots of
little points here. Okay, and that looks great. That's a brilliant starting point.
And also, you can see here that the trees are only within the bounding area, and the
grass is everywhere. So it's just an example of how you can create things in different
setups, but I quite like the grass being everywhere in this case. So now we're back
in the PCG graph, and we've sampled the surface and we've got a whole load of points.
Now, I am going to do a bit of a transformation at this point. So I'm going to drag off
and type in Transform Points, and I'm going to change some of the settings. Now,
there are a couple of things that I want to do on this transforming these points.
First one is, again, I want to randomize the Z axis. So we spin it on the Z axis
so that we get the points all pointing in a slightly different direction.
So I can visualize that if we jump back into the level. So you can see all of our grasses.
We're going to see from different angles, so we're not going to have to worry too much about
those. And I'm going to randomize the scale a little bit on these two. So I'm going to
make it so it has a maximum of one to two. So we get a slightly different scale.
And I'm going to put a little bit of an offset. So minus 30, minus 30, to 30, 30.
Now, why I've done this is it gives us a real kind of jumbling of everything.
Like even with the looseness down, you'll find that all the points are pretty uniform.
This will really shake them up. So we have them sort of all over the place,
slightly different sizes. We don't have to worry too much about overlapping when it comes
to grass because we want something that's pretty dense anyway. So it's not a major issue.
Okay, so we have our transform points. Now what I want to do is we've talked about density before.
We have never really used it in any means. You can see that we have some areas where
it's quite sloped and I don't want grass to be growing on these areas.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to try and filter those out.
Now, how I'm going to do that is I am going to use the density. I'm going to drag off
and I'm going to type normal to density. I'm going to turn off the debug here and turn it on
here. And what you will now see is everything turns grey. Now, it's not actually grey. What
it is, is if it's pointing directly up, it would be white. If it's pointing directly down,
it would be black. So it's applying a value to the density based on the normal.
Now, it still all looks pretty grey because 90% of these points are pointing directly up.
You can see that it's got a little bit darker grey here on where it's coming off to the edge,
but it's still pretty grey. So we can tell that it's working, but we're going to have an even
better idea of it working when we do the next thing, which is we are going to use a density
filter. Now, this is the first time that we started to use density as a value. So I'm going
to turn off the D here and I'm going to come into the D here. I only want grass to appear
where the density is almost one. So when it is pointing, the normal is pointing up.
So I'm going to change the lower bounds to 95 and upper bounds to one. So if we look, bang,
suddenly anything that is on a slope has now disappeared. And we can play around with that
value to get a different effect, but I quite like that. And I'm going to move this whole thing
a bit more central. So if we look at this from above, you can see that wherever is too sloped,
we now no longer have any grass reference here at all. OK, so that's looking pretty good.
However, I am not going to start generating grass yet, because at the moment it's too
blanket. It's still too uniform for me. I want a bit more kind of variation with this.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to put a different value into our density.
And I'm going to use a noise. So I'm going to type in and I'm going to search for spatial
noise. OK, and I'm going to D off on that, D off on here. And if we look at it,
we now see that we get gray here and a little bit here. Now that's not as varied enough for me.
So I'm going to change some of the settings. In the settings, I want to change. I'm happy with
it being Berlin 2D. But what I want is I want the Transform to be a lot larger. So we've
got it at 1. I'm going to change this to 50. OK, now if I was to look at the world,
you can see that we have a much higher kind of variant here. So the values that are being put
into density are from a per line noise generation. But it's giving us a value somewhere between
so low would be towards zero and high would be towards one. So that's great. At this point,
I can now start adding in meshes dependent on these values. So again, I am going to drag
off and I'm going to do another density filter. And for this density filter,
I am going to start off with anything between 0.3 and anything between 0.7.
That's where we're going to place our grass. So I'll turn that off there. If we look at it now,
we can see we just got rid of some of these. I'm going to play around with the numbers a bit more.
Maybe if I do the lower bounds too. Let's see what that looks like. That's too little.
I'm going to go four. That's all right. Maybe we'll play around with four. It doesn't matter
too much. You can get a slightly different look because we're doing this. OK, so I'm
going to drag off and add our trusty static mesh spawner. And for the static mesh spawner,
I want to add in the mesh entry. I want to add in a couple of mesh entries, actually.
I'm going to add in three. And again, I will search for static mesh so that I can see
just the static mesh entries. I'm looking for grass. So my grass one, my grass two,
and my grass three. And let's have a look at what we've got now.
Now, from a distance, you can't see much. But if we were to come in close,
maybe even play, you can see that we have a load of different grass.
Now, grass is something that I might turn the shadows off on because it gets a little bit
costly, but it's running quite fine. So we'll leave it for the time being.
But there you go. We have grass and we have grass and patches,
which I really like. You can see how we have these holes and that's from the noise.
Either that or it's a really, really uniform across the whole world.
Okay, so I like that. Let's go a little bit further and let's add some flowers in.
So I'm going to drag off this. I'm going to duplicate the control D.
I'm going to plug this in below. And for this, what I'm going to do is in the density.
So for that density, we have it going from 0 to 0.7. And this I'm going to have a little
bit of an overlap. So I'm going to go from 0.65, let's try that, to 1.
What we're going to do there is we are going to add in some flowers. Now, I know I've only
got two flower meshes, so I'm going to delete one of these and again, search for static mesh.
And I'm going to search for flower again. Okay, so now what we have, which I think is quite nice,
is towards the center of the element, we have bunches of flowers. And again,
we're using a fair few meshes here to get a bit of randomness, but it's got a real kind of,
it looks pretty, I kind of feel that's pretty realistic. It's mainly because of the layout,
but as we go through the grass, you can see that we have the different flowers popping.
That looks pretty good. Now you could come around and play with these different
values and that's going to change what percentage it is. Like if we wanted less
flowers, we could make that eight and oh, I couldn't make it eight. I don't feel like
there's much in the way of eight at all. So we can make it let's go seven.
There's a lot less flowers. We can play around with that. And these are our sort of variables
that we'll be able to use throughout. We can even expose some of them.
Okay. So that's pretty much that done. What I'm going to do though, very, very quickly
is just throw in some comments. So I will do that here just so that we know what we're doing.
Sample, landscape, and filter, lines point slope, and this will be
add grass, oops, add flowers, change that to a bit of green, and change that to a bit of purple.
One more thing that I might do, I think this is kind of optional with the grass,
but for good practice, I'll do that now. What I'm going to do is drag this out,
disconnect the density filter, drag off and do a difference.
As you will need this slightly later on. So we might as well do it now.
And with the difference again, I'm going to create it to binary and have the rocks
being placed into the difference. And I'm not going to worry about the trees and the bushes,
but that's going to mean that we're not spawning them inside of the rocks.
So that now looks like this. Okay, so and now we've got some good grass and we've got
some good flowers, and we can go from that point. And the next one, what we're going to
do is we're going to add a path to the system. Thanks a lot. I will catch you in the next video.